i knew that that national anthem did not
speak for people like me
in america the freedom liberty and
justice for all
is not for black people gwenberry knows
where what the math is here she knows
that she's going to get rich and famous
off of this nobody heard of her
yesterday everybody's heard of her today
let's talk about the issue of race in
the united states okay so
in order for us to live in a common
polity
we have to understand certain
basic agreements right even if you
believe in a sort of federalist
perspective a libertarian perspective
there have to be certain basic premises
which is that we all share a country for
a reason
and that the country is rooted in some
fundamental good
if you believe that the country is
fundamentally bad and wrong and it needs
to be completely remade
particularly along authoritarian lines
well that is going to lead to conflict
well half the country cheers that second
perspective at this point
right which is why you see gwen berry
making national news
we now live in a country where you
become more rich and more famous for
boycotting the national anthem
than you do for simply standing up for
the national anthem in baseball in the
1970s there was this very famous
circumstance where rick monday was an
outfielder at the time for the chicago
cubs
it was a wrigley field and rick monday
went and uh and grabbed a there was a
guy trying to he ran on the field he was
trying to burn american flag rick monday
came over and
grabbed the american flag away from him
and he was cheered for this today
the player himself would be lighting the
american flag on fire in the outfield
and the media would be cheering
for him so gwen berry has made
international headlines because at the
olympic trials she decided to turn her
face away from the flag
and to make faces during the national
anthem and then to post about what a
courageous
fighter she was the reason why we are
all paying attention to you when barry
is because you want us to pay attention
to you
you want the attention the quick path to
fame and riches in the united states is
to
crap all over the flag not to pay
attention to the flag being patriotic
is considered rote and hackneyed
burning the flag is considered forward
thinking and wonderful by at least half
the country which means there can't be
any sort of unified polity there have to
be some things that we agree on
on a broad level and by the way if
you're if you are representing the
united states in for example the pan
american games as gwen berry did right
she did in 2019
and she got in hot water with the
international
olympic committee the united states
olympic committee specifically because
she decided that she was going to
raise her fist during the national
anthem in protest of something or other
and um and then the new york times gave
her space right because that is how this
works so she's been attempting to get
attention for this sort of stuff for for
quite a while
despite the fact that gwenberry has
lived a pretty amazing life in the
united states as it turns out
when barry grew up in her grandparents
home there were 13 people in the home
in her grandmother's home and then she
had a baby out of wedlock at the age of
15.
got a scholarship to go to southern
illinois university
and she's made a career ever since
throwing a hammer that's kind of an
amazing thing in the united states
you don't hear a lot of stories like
that in other places but the utter
ingratitude
is the point so here is gwenberry
speaking to the new york times
it was just about a year ago talking
about how cruel it was that people were
angry at her for
protesting the american flag and the
national anthem again
while voluntarily joining a team to
represent the united states we're not
talking about
a regular even colin kaepernick playing
for an nfl team and deciding he doesn't
like the national anthem like adult
we're talking about somebody whose overt
job is to represent the united states
and we're supposed to cheer them when
they crap all over the united states
and the new york times thinks that this
is great here was
wenberry talking about this just last
year
so last summer at the pan american games
i threw 74 meters and i won gold
i remember the metal was so heavy and so
real i was excited
i was nervous
in that moment when the national anthem
was playing
i knew that that national anthem did not
speak for people like me
in america the freedom liberty and
justice for all
is not for black people something came
over me
i raised my fist
i felt like i was not at peace with
myself if i had not said something or
did something in that moment okay
let's point out something she says that
the national anthem and the flag are not
for her she is literally sitting there
wearing a shirt that says united states
pan american team with the american flag
on it
weird weird how you're very happy to
take the notoriety associated with
representing the united states
and then to crap all over the national
anthem and the american flag
but this has become mainstream thinking
on the left okay they they cannot offend
people
who wish to tear away any common symbol
of the united states
again i'm all for diversity of viewpoint
she has a right to protest she does
she doesn't have a right to to protest
while representing the united states per
se because it's a weird thing it's like
as charles cook of the national review
suggested it's like saying that you're
going to play for the new york yankees
you get signed by the new york yankees
you signed the contract and the first
thing you say is i'm never wearing
pinstripes i'm only wearing a red
uniform
like well no that's not how any of this
works but in the united states free
country she can say whatever she wants
if we are to have a common polity
however there has to be certain basic
agreements on certain things like you
don't get to invade
you know other people's individual
rights so her rights are not being
invaded also we should have a baseline
level of social agreement
that there are some common symbols that
carry some sort of sacred unity
representing those rights
but we don't want to unify over all that
so you have gensake from the white house
defending this sort of stuff
i haven't spoken to the president
specifically about this but i know he's
incredibly proud
to be an american and has great respect
for the anthem and all that
it represents especially for our men and
women serving in uniform all around
the world he would also say of course
that part of that pride in our country
means recognizing there are moments
where we are as a country haven't lived
up to our highest ideals
and it means respecting the right of
people granted to them in the
constitution to peacefully protest
well of course we respect the right of
people to peacefully protest it doesn't
mean you're not an idiot depending on
how you protest
but again this is gwenberry knows where
what the math is here she knows that
she's going to get rich and famous off
of this nobody heard of her yesterday
everybody's heard of her today
it's that simple an unhealthy country is
one that celebrates people
who spend their day tearing down the
country while purportedly representing
the country
that is not a particularly good thing
all these cultural issues matter
they do especially because the kind of
idea that america is inherently bad will
be crammed down on your kids
right it's not as though this is a a
everybody has their own perspective game
people in the united states government
right now in the educational system wish
to push
you to believe all the same sort of
stuff they wish to teach the 16 19
project in schools
they wish your kids to be indoctrinated
in this sort of
nonsense ideology in college
corporations mirror this sort of stuff
right that is a dangerous thing in the
united states
because this is a battle for power it is
and
it turns out the people who respect the
american flag the most are also the ones
who are basically going to be okay
with people in the private sphere doing
what exactly
wenberry does and again i'm fine with
that on a basic
kind of descent level but the people who
do what gwen berry does in control of
power are going to be
very intolerant of anybody having a
pro-america viewpoint
there's a bit of a zero-sum game going
on here
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like
and subscribe to help keep our videos on
the front line of the fight and top of
your feed